my name is Bowden Kelly I worked at
Microsoft I'm a program manager working
on JavaScript tools including typescript
nodejs and other tooling support in
Visual Studio and Visual Studio code but
today we're looking at specifically how
to get you from 0 to 60 with typescript
in node.js we only have 25 minutes so
we're gonna go kind of fast it'll be
very demo driven if you have questions
hold them to the end and I'll try to get
them in time if you get nothing else
from this session I want you to
understand why typescript is worth your
time you know there's a lot of tools out
there there's a lot of technologies
these days for a JavaScript developer to
consider and if you take nothing else
away you should understand why why
typescript what does it aim to do and
we'll get to that right off the bat I'm
also going to show you how to get
productive fast in whatever environment
you're currently in and then finally I'm
going to show you just a little bit of
typescript in action so why typescript
we think it's pretty simple
we believe that developers should be
able to focus on creating amazing things
and creating is bold here because that's
what we all aim to do with code you know
code is just a tool at the end of the
day to help us build services and
products and experiences to truly why
our users but in reality that's not
really how we spend our time if you take
every activity you do on a week-to-week
basis in your development cycles you can
fall into three broad categories
understanding code this is you know
reading the existing code looking up
documentation finding bugs maintaining
existing code so this includes
refactoring and preparing for new
features and fixing those bugs that you
know already exist and then finally
finally after you've done all of those
things if you've paid all that tax you
can actually write new code and deliver
new experiences we found with JavaScript
in particular the larger your code base
grows the more complicated it gets and
the harder it gets to focus on creation
as anyone familiar with Monaco
how about vias code so Monaco is where
vias code started the idea was we wanted
to take an editor environment and put it
in the browser and so as such this was
all written in JavaScript and we found
that as this code base hit three hundred
four hundred four thousand lines of code
it became really hard to focus on
creation and we actually kind of
measured we said how long are we
spending on each of these buckets and
what we found is a vast
our time was just trying to understand
what our code was even doing then we
spent about 25 percent of our time
maintaining and then finally five
percent or two hours and a 40-hour
workweek actually trying to build that
that editor in the browser and we said
you know this this is not this is not
good enough we can definitely do better
what would it take what if we could take
this split and just build some tools
such that minor savings from
understanding and maintenance could add
to creation time instead and what would
that tool look like and it was chasing
that idea that we created typescript now
what exactly is typescript the technical
definition is an optionally type
superset of JavaScript that compiles to
plain JavaScript but I've always found
it easier just to show rather than tell
so here we are in a JavaScript file this
is a random javascript file that we took
out of a random project and to get
started with typescript to see what
typescript does all we're gonna do is
add a single comment and it's going to
be TS check at the top of our file and
what this is gonna do is it's gonna flag
this in vs code and this is you know vs
code by the way if you're unfamiliar you
should check it out it's a great editor
but if you just put TS check at the top
it's gonna flag this file and say hey I
want you go type check this JavaScript
for me you know do nothing else just run
the typescript type checker and tell me
if anything looks off and right off the
bat you see we have some red squiggles
this is actually not even part of the
demo but Zee object I guess that's a
typo my bad but a type so it's gonna
look at all these things and see what
makes sense or what doesn't make sense
and in this case Z object they don't
know what that is
and so they flag it and in fact it was a
typo it was a mistake so we can delete
that out we could look at the next
mistake argument of type this string
literal value in read-only is not
assignable to the parameter property
descriptor and so what's happening here
is javascript has types it is
dynamically typed so they can change and
they're not necessarily enforced ever
but they do have types types exist under
the scenes and that's what typescript
looking at and so if we look at this
define property method we can see that
there are in fact types that javascript
expects at runtime and if we look at
this property descriptor there are a
limited set of options that you can pass
through and
anything that isn't in this set this is
going to get ignored by JavaScript at
runtime it doesn't care right and so
we're gonna look at this we're C
configurable and numerable value and
writable and we can see that back in our
code we used read-only so probably what
we intended was to say writable false or
actually true and you see our error goes
away but what would I have been a
runtime again if I pass in read-only
into this method it's gonna look at it
it's going to see that it doesn't match
what's expecting that's gonna pretend
like it never saw anything and so now
you have a misconfigured object your
method it may be behaving in a way that
you didn't expect and you don't even
have an error to point you to the right
direction where where your code went
wrong and that's what typescript does it
points you in the right direction here
we have another mistake where we see
operator greater than cannot be applied
to some function and a number if we look
at ship weight sure enough it's a
function that returns the parse int of
some text so probably what we intended
to do was call this function but we
didn't write and this is this is a
common mistake I've done this thousands
of times but you won't catch this until
runtime and in fact that runtime what's
going to happen when you compare a
function and a number it's false it's
not an error it's not true it's false
and so this code is going to be
misbehaving you will never find that
you're you know shipping weight is over
a hundred it will always return false
and you'll have no idea why your codes
misbehaving typescript can help you save
you from these little mistakes but this
is just JavaScript right we haven't done
anything to change what's going on here
typescript is just looking at your
existing JavaScript because typescript
is a superset of JavaScript but what
else can we do with typescript well we
can start adding types in this function
we have an email address parameter and
typescript setting this is in any and so
right now it doesn't know anything about
this parameter but we can tell it we can
say hey I've got this comment here that
says it can be a string or a string
array so I'm going to use a J's comment
because again we're still in a j-style
I'm going to say this is a string or a
string array and now typescript knows
from this J's comment that we want this
to be a string or a string array and now
I can continue type checking the rest of
your code with this assumption that this
is what you're saying it is and here we
find a
mistake where we have misspelled trim
because Trin is not a function off of
email address and so basically what
you're seeing here is typescript is just
JavaScript typescript is just additional
tools to help you write better
JavaScript to take care of the little
mistakes and let you focus on what
you're actually trying to build and so
where are you supposed to take away from
that quick demo really you can start
using type checking JavaScript today
it's very simple in vs code all you have
to do is out of comment to the top of
your file using TS check will get you
started fast you don't have to deal with
configuration you don't have to deal
with config files or build set ups all
you have to do is add that comment and
then you can slowly start adding jsoc
comments with types in them to
experiment with what types would be like
what is it like to work with a type
system you don't have to jump in all at
once so you get it you see you can add a
type system type checking to JavaScript
but does it really work a lot of people
think that you know I'm fine without
type checking it wouldn't really help me
that much
well for the skeptics out there there
has been a empirical research on this
where they took 400 code bases on github
they looked at bugs that made it into
production and then they went back and
applied both slow and typescript to
those code bases to see if a compile
time type checker would have prevented
that bug from ever making it to
production and they found that 15% of
those 400 bugs would have never made it
into production and been caught by a
type checker and so it works type
systems work so so you saw how we can
start type checking JavaScript but type
scripts more than that typescript is a
superset and it really allows a lot more
features than you just saw and so to
show you how you can convert an entire
existing Express code base I'm gonna
take this simple app which is a basic
Express app it's actually a pared down
sample from a QuickStart and basically
it gives you a boilerplate for a node.js
Express application it's got some basic
templates it's got authentication using
passport you know I can login and it's
really just a starting point you know
many people use these to get started
with their applications these days and
so this is what we're gonna start with
and I'm going to convert this JavaScript
code base to typescript just to show you
how easy it is and some of the things
you get once you do and so as you can
see we've got a node modules folder a
node modules backup folder because I'm
very paranoid about having internet
during demos you've got a source folder
a lot of JavaScript files in here and
then your basic config files and so the
first thing to do to get going with you
know the full-blown typescript
is you need a TS config and so I'm gonna
type P Afyon it from the integrated
terminal in vs code and it's going to
generate me a TS config file and we're
going to see in this TS config file is a
ton of options right but these are all
commented out these are basically every
option you could pass into T as config
with an explanation of what it is and so
it's very useful for getting familiar
with what your options are but we
already know what we need and so I'm
just going to delete this and cut
straight to the chase we're targeting
node so we can use es6 commonjs is fine
we want to use a loud j s and what this
is going to let us do is pass both
javascript and typescript into the
compiler and i'll show you what that
means in a second we didn't want a out
directory and we'll call this disc for
distribution and then finally we want a
module resolution to be node and this is
just going to tell the types of compiler
I'm in a node application I'm targeting
a node environment you should do module
resolution in the same kind of way that
I would expect in node the last thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to include
[Music]
my source file as you see here I have a
source directory and that will basically
set the route in which typescript
consumes source files and so now when I
run TSC which invokes the typescript
compiler you will see that I made a
mistake
oh you're right
thank you so this is just a globbing
pattern and I reversed that on accident
so we're going to run it you're gonna
see we now have a dist folder inside
this disk folder is the same thing we
put in we just passed in JavaScript
files and we got out JavaScript files
and you'll notice these are exactly the
same which is good so we can now convert
we have our compiler setup we can now
convert our first file from jazz to TS
and once we've done this we can now you
know write typescript as we would expect
where we can add type annotations in
line to functions and then when we call
the function if we don't pass in the
correct type it will complain right we
are now in a type script file a types of
environment the compiler is checking
this by default now but notice the rest
of my files are still JavaScript so I
can now run TSC again and it will take
all of the typescript files in this
source file convert them to JavaScript
and we'll take all of the JavaScript
files and just basically pass them
through the compiler and we'll put them
all in my distribution folder so that I
can still run my app so now I can still
do node and this time we'll go from dist
and we'll put server and that's not it
and fire it up and you'll see that it is
in fact still working as we'd expect
nothing has changed so this is the part
where if you have a large project you
might want to go file by file one file
at a time convert it to typescript do
your work and make it the conversion in
a piecemeal fashion but because this is
a small project and there's only a
handful of files I'm just going to go
ahead and convert these all to TS just
so you can see what that conversions
going to be like and so we're gonna run
TSC again and this is where you start to
run into the first kind of friction from
converting right we're gonna get a
couple of errors and you see a bunch of
them or cannot read Eclair this block
scope variable passport right and
basically what's happening here is if we
go look at passport TS we can see we've
got squiggles on our imports and this is
a
kind of complicated subject if you dealt
with modules in JavaScript before you
know that it's a pretty deep rabbit hole
and so I'm not gonna go too in depth
here but basically this this code is
written and require using you know
common j/s what we need it to be is an
es6
so the typescript compiler can
understand it and then return it back to
commonjs
and so to do that we can just use this
handy reg X that I have in this sketchy
unsaved notepad file and what this reg X
is going to do is it can take all of our
import statements and convert them to
the es6 import star syntax I just want
to do that you'll see it highlights all
of my imports I can go ahead and execute
that and it's going to replace them all
in mine and I now have import star as
passport from passport and you see the
types of compiler is not happy the other
thing I have to do is if I change my
imports I also got changed my exports
and so we'll do that real quick to good
make sure we don't change anything in
jQuery that would be bad
and all of our exports get changed as
well now this isn't a perfect conversion
this was just a real quick regex I wrote
right you know before this and so
there's a couple places where it doesn't
do exactly what we want for example when
we're trying to export our model we use
modules export instead of export equals
or exports equals rather and so we have
to go clean this up by hand but you
could write a much better you're ready
regex than I could and make this
actually work and so we're going to
switch this to export default user and
you'll see why we want to default in a
while and then we also need to switch
this module export to export app export
equals app there we go so now we're
going to go ahead and check our problems
list to see where our remaining problems
are and it looks like we've got one more
error again this is another module thing
because of the way expressed validator
exposes itself in in their module we
have to use a slightly separate syntax
for the
module this is pretty rare but Express
validator is the one that you'll
experience in a node project where you
have to say import Express validator
equals require instead of from Express
validator again kind of a nuisance but
it comes into this whole inherited
module problem that we have so now let's
look at some of the remaining errors we
have and so this one will tell us that
property ID does not exist on this type
which is an empty object and if we look
at this we can see that you know
serialized user has a full function body
and if we look at that this is actually
a DTS file that we have hiding in the
project and this is where I have to to
lie to you a little bit I went ahead and
downloaded all the DTS files for this
project ahead of time again for internet
reasons but basically what happens here
is if we go to our package JSON we can
get the type definitions for just about
every single node module by going to at
types which is basically a community
that's on github that just contributes
all of their own Taipings to a community
and we can download them by using the
add type scope on NPM and so when I say
at types last expression session I'm
getting the DTS file for express session
and you can see I have a number of DTS
files that I've gone ahead and grabbed
and all of these are imports that I use
somewhere in this project and what this
does is in my node modules folder you
will see I have an @ types folder and in
here I have a DTS file for every single
one of these which contains the types
which will let me type check the code
this is really great because this is
basically free value right typically
when you're using a type checker you
have to provide the types for them to
check when you use a DTS file someone
has already gone and done all of the
work of adding those types for you and
you just get to benefit from their labor
so that's great but so we're looking at
this and we're saying okay well there's
a problem here
ID does not exist on this you know user
but this is our user model this is the
thing that you know we defined use for
Mongoose right and basically what we
need to tell typescript here is this is
a little more specific than just an
empty object in fact it is a mongoose
document and so we can import document
sorry we can import from Mongoose
document which is a type again that has
already been defined for us if we look
at that we can see this is a DTS file
again and someone has gone ahead and
defined all of the things that exist on
a mongoose document and now we can say
this user is actually of type document
and that that error will go away but not
all of the errors go away and if we look
at okay we have another problem here
where we're importing user incorrectly
if we right-click and go to definition
on this user we see we just end up in
this file but not on the actual user we
export and so the issue in this case is
because we use the default export we
have to alias the import so we say
default as user and then we're all
better anyway it's back to our back to
our user model if we look at this user
model we'll add document here again and
we'll expect to resolve this error
except in this case it doesn't work and
that's because compare password is a
method that we added on to our user
model in Mongoose and so we've added
this custom method it doesn't exist on
the document and so we need some way to
extend document and say you know this
isn't just a document this is a user
document and so what you can do is you
can create a type in type script so
we'll export type user document and
we'll say that this is a mongoose
document and some additional stuff and
what this is is an intersection type
this ampersand basically says I have one
type that I want to start with and I
want to throw more stuff into it to
create some new type which we'll call
user document and so we'll add compare
password here
and we'll make it an innie just for now
and when we go back to our document and
we make this now a user document oh we
got to import it first sorry
wrong place when we now make this a user
document you'll see that our error goes
away and indeed if we look at this user
we can see that we have the base
document stuff on it like ID for example
but we also have our function compare
password which is of type in E and so we
can actually do much better than this
because when we defined this model there
was a bunch of stuff in it right we have
you know profile which has a bunch of
strings and password and password token
and so again back to my sketchy notepad
we can grab the type and type out
exactly what we want this type to be
it'll go ahead and format this real
quick and now when we refer to it now
that we've added you know all of the
properties that exist on this type when
we actually use it or in passport we can
see that we have access to all of those
things so if I look at profile we have
profile and we can see all of the
properties that exist inside profile and
so again typescript is just helping you
here it's telling you what your options
are what's available if you make a
mistake and try to you know do something
that's not there it's going to tell you
this property does not exists on this
model that you created and it's going to
give you basically the help you need to
focus on what you're trying to build
let's see last one this is also an
import error where we're importing user
and this needs to be a default and with
that we should be done we've now
converted all of our files to typescript
we can run TSC and see that it does
compile to our distributed folder and it
comes back clean there's no errors if we
run node on that server and we started
up we can see that our application still
works as we expect right but now we're
in like a fully typed environment we're
not fully typed yet we're in a
typescript capable environment so we can
start adding types wherever we want
and so from here on out you can use
typescript or types when it's helpful
and ignore them when it's not and so if
we go look at user TS this controller
for example you can see that we have
requests and responses all throughout
this file where we don't have types yet
and so if we want to we can import from
Express request and response and now we
can add these types in line and so what
this does is if you look at you know
before we add it if I do request dot I
get nothing right our editor knows
nothing about this thing but as soon as
I tell it what it is and again we're
taking advantage of types that other
users have already defined for us if we
look at this we can see that there is
really a lot of work that has been done
here that we can just take advantage of
right away when we start using these
things we now get great help great tools
great support if we make mistakes the
compiler is going to catch it if we just
want to you know write code and see what
the you know functions do or their
signatures do you can get all of that
right in your editor and so you don't
have to flip back and forth between
documentation you don't have to spend
your time trying to figure out what
those methods are that you can call you
can spend more time actually doing the
work you want to do that looks like
that's about all the time I have I want
to call out that this is a tiny sample
taken from a larger sample if you get a
Microsoft slash typescript node starter
this is a repo that we maintain so that
you can see what a node and type script
repository looks like and look at other
best practices like testing and CI and
setting up vs code with tasks JSON and
debugging configurations all of that
stuff lives in this repository we don't
have time to go over today but I
encourage you to check it out if you're
interested
final kind of kind of takeaways I
encourage you if you've never used a
type checker before download via skoda
throw at TS check at the top of your
file just to see what happens you may be
surprised and find that you have a
couple bugs lurking it also may be
totally clean the worst that
happen is nothing right I also would
encourage you to think about adding
typescript to any of your current
workflows because it really works
anywhere you can lay it on top in about
what 10 minutes we just added it to an
Express application but you can really
add it to any kind of node project
you're using today and finally the point
of all of this whether it's using node
whether it's using typescript any of
these tools is to help you focus on
building cool stuff you know services
products experiences for customers and I
encourage you to think about that next
time you're working on a project how can
I be more productive we think typescript
in node can help you do that thank you
[Applause]